you
keuner I've been getting it all morning
I turn on the air compression tool
anymore you guys just don't appreciate
good music you feel pretty good today
don't you yank on top of the world
trying to bite figure why a guy should
feel so happy getting these hands back
in the grease you might figure different
if somebody told you you couldn't get
your hands greasy Steve maybe you will
think it's funny but lots of times when
I was lying in bed looking at the
ceiling I used to dream up repair jobs
and then go through them step by step
now that I've got my hands on some real
engines again I'm not kicking what was
it like that Jack in the hospital it was
no picnic
not very well I mean what what what is
it like to have TV what happens how do
you know when you have it
trouble is you generally don't know I
didn't
I felt tired all the time played out I
didn't call you can have TV without
calling but I was taking some pills I'd
heard about I figured I'd snap out of it
I always had before I didn't think too
much of it
then I would sweat at night used to wake
up wringing wet
hell I'm worried about it you know how
women are she wanted me to go to the
doctor I told her you don't get meet any
doctor unless I'm really safe I guess I
never would have found out in time if it
hadn't been for that community x-ray
program you know and that Taylor came
around and a lot of us had those chess
pictures made
next thing I knew doc Whipple called up
that's her family doctor he said Jack
can you stop by the office soon I want
to talk to you I said okay I still
didn't humble thought maybe you wanted
to talk to me about the kids or
something
when I did go he let me have it easy it
seems the x-ray fellas had sent him the
report on me because I given his name as
my doctor he said he didn't like the
looks of it and he wanted a bigger
picture made so I went and got a big
picture and doc Whipple went over it
with a specialist
that did it Matt and some other test
they made I had TB and it was well
underway he said that I'd have to go to
a hospital he did well I told him doc I
can I can't stop working what will
happen to Helen on the kids that's the
first thing you worry about the money
but the doctor had an answer what will
happen to them if you don't get well of
course he was right but it's hard to see
your way clear at first I hated to go
home that day we had a little put buy
savings bonds but not enough to last a
year the doctor thought it might take
about that long I figured that we lose
the house that Helen had worked so hard
over and I was worried for the
youngsters had always planned with him
to get more schooling than I did I
didn't know what to do
but Helen did she said I was going to
the hospital right away
she's a great hand at budgeting that
girl she showed me that with the savings
bonds and taking some loans on the
insurance we could manage somehow and
she said she wasn't too proud to ask for
help from the agencies that Whipple had
mentioned
a few days later I went to the hospital
right over a charge avail a lot of
people still think you have to go to the
mountain to the Taser that's the book
climate isn't the important thing the
reason for going to a tuberculosis
Hospital instead of staying home is that
the whole setup is geared for one thing
Trading tuberculosis they have all the
equipment there and they know what
they're doing
I won't pretend I liked it there nobody
likes being in a hospital but I'm sure
glad I went for one thing I wasn't
spreading my own TB germs to my family
or friends that was the best of care and
the right kind of food
and rest rest rest that's the main thing
in beating tuberculosis rest
the doctor told me why that is you get
to know a lot about TV when you're in
the hospital
you see almost everybody has healthy
lungs to begin with you have to get TB
germs from somebody else maybe from them
coughing or sneezing or spitting when
you breathe in those germs they may get
a foothold in the lungs just like seeds
taking root but the body fights back by
growing a kind of covering around them
so they can't spread they call this a
tubercle and it's like a scar that holds
the germs ins they can't do any harm
usually you don't know that this is
happening lots of people have two /
goals and they get along alright for
years but then maybe the tubercle breaks
down or more likely you breathe in some
more germs again they may spread faster
than the body can stop them then you're
in real trouble the TB gets into the air
pockets of the lung and destroys them
makes holes in the long run this can
kill you the reason you need so much
rest in bed is that the lung doesn't
have to move much and that makes it
easier for the body to fight off the
germs I asked the doctor about
operations they have different ones they
can use for different cases no two cases
of TB or just a life
for me he planned a pneumothorax this is
one way of getting an infected lung
arrest
they put a hollow needle through the
chest wall and let's sterile air into it
this collapses the lung then it doesn't
have to work to breathe so the healing
begins the other lung does all of
breathing you need a push in time the
air put in around along is absorbed but
they can easily keep it collapsed with
more air
I had a refill every so often what
surprised me was that it it didn't cause
any pain though at times it was
uncomfortable they had drugs now too
that helped a lot in some cases I was
lucky enough to respond well to one of
the new drugs and I got regular shots of
it
there's another angle to this business
of licking TB may be the hardest one
your state of mind I used to get to
press sometimes he wouldn't be human if
you didn't it's easy to say rest and
don't worry what you do worry about a
lot of things mostly I worried about my
family then I wondered how it would be
when I came back would I be able to
handle my job again what fellas like you
accept me as an equal it sounds silly
but it's real enough at the time and
it's bad for you unless your minds easy
your body can't fight
of course one thing that snapped me out
of it was when Helen came to visit
that's one advantage of being in a
hospital near home we had plenty to talk
about the kids and all seeing her would
chase away the glooms make me know I had
to get well and the people in the
hospital keep an eye on your mental
state too they know they said in a
rehabilitation man to talk to me about
my work I told him that I just wanted to
be a mechanic again and after talking to
the doctors he agreed to that but he
figured I ought to have an extra string
to my bowl just in case he was smart he
sent me a course on part service
inventory control and it was practical
because I knew all about parts from the
other end and I did feel easier knowing
that I had something to fall back on
they keep a constant check on you x-rays
and other tests well it seems a long
time and then I found that I was getting
better the doctor told me I was making
some headway and could get up for a
little exercise
just a few steps first but I tell you I
was as pleased and proud as a kid with
his first Christmas tree
they let you exercise by slow degrees
just a little more each day but finally
I was able to navigate as well as ever
that builds up your confidence
at last I was ready to come back like I
say that I won't pretend I liked it
there but the people in that hospital
were swell to me it's true you have to
cure yourself but you can't do it
without their help
coming back was wonderful but it's not a
clean break you just don't go charging
out into the world with a chip on your
shoulder we had a little celebration the
first night at home just the family but
not late you have to make adjustments in
the way you live that's one word you get
to know when you've had TV adjustments
so I remember to get to bed on time
like when you go back to work
you can't always handle full-time at
first the boss was swell about that he
had talked to my doctor and fixed it so
I could work in the Flex department just
mornings
that was three months ago remember that
part-time job didn't tire me so I was
anxious to get back to the old job
there's another thing you learned to get
used to when you come back they warned
me about it at the hospital some people
are afraid of you think they're going to
catch TB if you get near them can't say
I blame them but they're all wrong they
don't discharge you from a hospital and
send you home until it's safe all around
of course I was going regular dockworker
for check-ups last week he gave me the
word I was waiting for said I was well
enough now how to get back to the old
jar full-time believe me fellows it's a
wonderful feeling to know that you've
come all the way back and you're a
full-time man again that's great to have
you back full-time Jack need it to stay
that way see that you stay that way -
who me yes you both of you
the main reason I told you my story was
to sell you one idea get a physical
examination regularly
and a chest x-ray if you haven't had one
for a year make a date soon it's the
smartest thing you can do I know what
I'm talking about
you